on a Hot August Night in 1952 George
hunt Williamson and his wife Betty
cleared away the dinner they'd enjoyed
with another couple at their home in
Winslow Arizona
next Williamson produced a homemade
Ouija board with a shot glass serving as
the board's pointer
the 26 year old Williamson and his
friend Alfred Bailey moved the glass
around the board while Betty Williamson
took notes and Bailey's wife also named
Betty looked on mystified
the men weren't trying to contact
anyone's dear departed Aunt Tilly no
they were trying to contact
extraterrestrials whom they called the
space intelligences
a mutual fascination with flying saucers
had sparked their correspondence two
months earlier
that Curiosity persuaded bayley to make
the two-hour drive from Winslow to
Prescott
his in Williamson's hope of making
contact that night wasn't disappointed
the Ouija board conjured up space
intelligences with exotic names such as
Zoe of Neptune Zago of Mars and na nine
the contact sessions continued over the
next few months first switching to Morse
code Transmissions via shortwave radio
and then to Williamson acting as a
Channel or medium in other words instead
of using modern technology Williamson
ultimately opted for a method employed
by countless shamans Sorcerers Mystics
and profits before him
he listened to the voices in his head
Williamson displayed a remarkable talent
for channeling many different aliens
from many different planets in many
different voices
he and Bailey would co-author a book
about their experience the saucer speak
which remains a classic of UFO lore
so what did the voices say we'll come
back to that
in this episode we're going to plunge
into the wild weird and very woolly
realm of unidentified flying objects
Alfred Bailey quickly faded from the
scene but George hunt Williamson went on
to become a major figure in the
so-called contactee movement I.E those
who believe they'd made personal contact
be it physical or psychic with
extraterrestrial beings
indeed Williamson became one of the four
Georges of the golden age of flying
saucers along with George damsky George
King and George Van Tassel
what these men had in common besides
UFOs was their immersion in occult
beliefs and practices
in popular imagination UFOs are usually
connected with space aliens advanced
technology and science not trans mediums
magic and just maybe demons but they are
it's a good place to recall scientist
and author Arthur C Clarke's Third Law
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
the modern UFO age arguably began in
June 1947 when pilot Kenneth Arnold
spotted nine gleaming bouncing
unidentified craft near Washington's
Mount Rainier
Arnold was pretty much a nuts and bolts
guy but even he came to believe that
there was something well Supernatural
about the saucers
the subject of UFOs remains wide open
for debate today
but there's no doubting the reality of
the UFO phenomenon even the U.S military
admits that after eliminating all of the
misidentification swamp gas and flat out
hoaxes there remains a disturbing number
of UFO sightings that defy explanation
to Seekers like George hunt Williamson
UFOs became part of that vast hidden
reality that only occultism can access
and reveal
I'd agree the UFO phenomenon and the
Occult have much in common two sides of
the same saucer if you will
so we'll focus attention on the Golden
Age of flying saucers the decade or so
after Arnold's initial sighting a period
when a cult ufoed him sprang forth in
all its Glory
George hunt Williamson had a vivid
Fantasy Life
that's another way of saying that he was
a habitual liar
still Williamson was able to manifest
some of those fantasies into a semblance
of reality
for example
he repeatedly claimed to hold an
academic doctorate in fact he never even
completed a bachelor's degree
but through what occultist Aleister
Crowley might call an active will plus
some decent acting he was able to
convince most people that he did
Williamson was drawn to the occult early
on
he recalled psychic experiences as a boy
and an out of body episode in college
he also dabbled in spiritualism when he
first encountered Ouija boards and
channeling
Williamson also found inspiration in the
book owaspe a new Bible
this is an 1880s work channeled by a
spiritualist dentist named John nubrow
who put a new Twist on automatic writing
by using a typewriter
through these Revelations new Bro
learned that Angelic ambassadors
piloting Starships came to Earth eighty
thousand years ago to initiate the
physical and spiritual evolution of
humans
another influence on Williamson was the
I am movement founded by the Californian
guy Ballard
it was basically a 20th century American
rehash of Helena blavasky's theosophical
Society
in the 1930s it garnered more than a
million followers
Ballard claimed to have been whisked
away on a flaming Circle to meet
ascended masters from Venus in the Grand
Teton Mountains
these same venusians allegedly channeled
Timeless wisdom to Ballard to share with
his followers
just like the space intelligences would
later do for Williamson
and George hunt Williamson's psychic
Adventures lead straight to our next
George Georgia damski arguably the most
famous of the early contactees
the polish-born adamsky's career
included stints as a Cavalry trooper and
house painter but mostly he met his
living as a purveyor of mysticism
in the 1930s he founded the Royal order
of Tibet in where else Southern
California
it promised to dispense the teachings of
universal magic as channeled by adamsky
from superhuman llamas somewhere in the
Himalayas
so yes it too we see it another rip-off
of theosophy
when the whale of Tibetan wisdom ran dry
adamsky turned to the new craze of
flying saucers
on November 20th 1952 Williamson Bailey
and their wives joined the damski on a
saucer Hunting Expedition in
California's Mojave Desert
this allegedly led to adamsky's famous
face-to-face encounter with a blonde
androgynous platitude-spouting venusian
named orthon
and what did orthon Zoe Zago and the
rest of the space intelligences have to
say well they didn't offer any practical
pointers for space travel or cure for
cancer instead they lectured about
Humanity's desperate need for Spiritual
Enlightenment and the cataclysmic Perils
of nuclear energy
the rest of the Galaxy it seems was very
very worried about us
others were getting the same message or
in on the same Act
in May 1954 London cabbie George King
said he was driving along when a voice
popped into his head proclaiming prepare
yourself you are to become the voice of
the interplanetary parliament
King duly formed the aetherius society
which is still around
members conduct rituals to soar psychic
prayer energy or magical intention in
radionic batteries
during the mid-1950s California Psychics
Ernest and Ruth Norman also began
channeling interplanetary light beings
and soon expanded into a full-fledged
saucer cult called The unarius Academy
of Science
they emphasized reincarnation and
elaborate costumed Karma cleansing
rituals which they dubbed psychodramas
while the space Brothers generally
presented a benevolent if condescending
facade there was often the direct or
implied threat that if humans couldn't
get their act together outside
intervention would be necessary
now if you think that sounds straight
out of the 1951 film The Day the Earth
Stood Still you're right the question is
did the movie influence the saucer Cults
or did they influence it
from an occult standpoint maybe the most
significant thing is that like the
angels of old the saucer men carefully
selected those to whom they imparted
Celestial wisdom
oddly these were almost never scientists
mainstream religious leaders or
politicians maybe the aliens knew better
than to trust anyone who'd already
screwed up so badly
in occultism one must be worthy of
Enlightenment that leads us to another
George George Van Tassel who quit his
job as an inspector with Lockheed
aircraft in the Fateful year of 1947 and
moved his family to an isolated spot in
the Mojave Desert about 50 miles north
of Palm Springs
called giant rock the spot boasted a
massive Granite Boulder seven stories
tall plus a small Airfield and Cafe that
phantasel ran as a dude ranch for
weekend Pilots
George Van Tassel seemed a pretty
regular guy until 1952 when he too
started getting telepathic messages from
space beings
the most notable was ashtar later a
favorite of other occultist contactees
some have noted that ashtar sounds a lot
like ashtaroth or osteroth a powerful
demon or Fallen Angel mentioned in old
grimoires
astoroth was said to project a fair
appearance and to be knowledgeable of
every science
regardless of who or what Van Tassel was
communicating with he held his
channeling sessions in a kind of Crypt
carved out beneath the giant rock
a typical session would begin with Van
Tassel tuning in to his alien guides and
blurting out something like I am Knute I
bring you love
he produced a book about his experiences
titled I wrote a flying saucer but his
biggest contribution to the emerging
field of ufology was organizing the
first interplanetary spacecraft
convention in 1953
it became an annual event a kind of
Burning Man for saucer heads drawing
thousands for nearly a quarter century
adamsky and Williamson were regular
attendees Van Tassel also founded the
College of universal wisdom to promote
the benign philosophy of the space
people
under their alleged guidance he began to
build a large Observatory looking
structure dubbed the Integratron
by focusing intentions and Cosmic
energies and using harmonic resonance
the Integratron was supposed to manifest
all manner of Miracles
most importantly it would extend human
life so that we could attain
Enlightenment without all those pesky
reincarnations
the Integratron remained unfinished when
Van Tassel passed on in 1978 but it
still stands as this giant rock
some argue that the whole UFO phenomenon
has its origins in an occult working
conducted in the Mojave in early 1946.
at the center of it was one of English
magician Aleister Crowley's followers
rocket scientist John Whiteside Parsons
along with being a pioneer of caltech's
jet propulsion laboratory and the U.S
Space Program Jack Parsons was an avid
occultist he liked to invoke pan at
Rocket tests and even proclaimed himself
the Antichrist
but he became most obsessed with the
idea of incarnating the Goddess Babylon
the Scarlet woman of Revelation his aim
to acquire a magical soulmate
to accomplish this Parsons recruited
another aspiring occultist ex-navy
officer and future founder of
Scientology L Ron Hubbard
soon after Parsons met the love of his
life a fiery redhead named Marjorie
Cameron
but the theory goes He unwittingly
managed more than that
Parsons opened a door and something flew
in the something being flying saucers
and the Demonic entities controlling
them
this notion became the fixation of
another shadowy group popping up in 1952
the so-called Collins Elite
ostensibly formed by U.S military and
intelligence officials the Collins Elite
concluded that the intelligences behind
UFOs were nothing less than demonic
entities From Another Dimension bent on
consuming human Souls
Jack Parsons died in a mysterious
explosion in June 1952.
soon after much of the country including
Washington DC was swarmed with UFO
sightings
his mate Marjorie Cameron interpreted
this as Cosmic acknowledgment of Parsons
death
Marjorie Cameron went on to experience
strange encounters with UFOs for the
rest of her life even becoming Pals with
George Van Tassel
it was also around the time of Parsons
fiery death that Williamson adamsky Van
Tassel and others started channeling
their Spacemen
did Parsons open some sort of portal or
was there something else in the air or
the water and what about Aleister
Crowley did he have any E.T connections
well maybe
Crowley's death in 1947 and the
appearance of UFOs that same year seems
more than coincidental according to
Modern occultist Alan Greenfield
some also smell a UFO Connection in
Crowley's reported encounters with
non-human entities such as I was and
lamb
iwas was the being who dictated the
so-called book of the law to Crowley in
1904.
lamb was another entity who Crowley
magically summoned in 1918 and 1919.
Crowley's portrait of lamb shows a
bulbous head with small features in
which many see the familiar face of a
modern gray alien though to be honest I
don't
UFOs and strange beings connected to
them didn't just suddenly appear in
1947.
UFO researcher Jacques valet makes an
excellent case that modern alien
encounters including alleged abductions
strongly resemble old Tales of fairies
gin and demons
it raises the unsettling possibility
that we might be dealing with beings
capable of assuming many different faces
in pursuit of some hidden that is a cult
agenda
with that in mind let's look at a
pre-1947 UFO Incident That's a sort of
Steampunk meets X-Files it took place in
Utah during World War One
in the spring of 1917 Salt Lake City
Newspapers ran reports of mystery lights
and strange airships Witnesses were
mostly respectable folk including a
County Sheriff
some local men popped up to claim that
they were the builders and operators of
The Craft
the United States had just entered the
first world war so there was concern
that these nocturnal Antics could be
part of some dastardly German plot
Leon bone the Federal Bureau of
Investigations local agent decided to
get to the bottom of things
he looked up the men and found them more
than willing to talk
their leader was a local Freemason named
John Van valkenberg
and he proceeded to spin agent bone an
incredible Tale
it began out in the Nevada desert where
Van valkenberg claimed that he had
encountered a being variously called the
Adept The Fountainhead the superpower
the old man or the above one
according to Van valkenberg the Adept
lived in a giant airship in stationary
orbit high above the Earth
the being gave him a small spinning disc
device no bigger than a human fist
which van valkenberg and his Pals used
to power the craft that they used to
reach the mothership and zip around at
night
then valkenberg fantastically claimed
that the craft could travel at a
thousand miles an hour to any altitude
was immune to weather and more amazingly
yet consumed no fuel
the disc thingy simply negated gravity
van valkenberg mentioned Visiting San
Francisco Washington DC and also a
marvelous land inhabited by a peaceful
technologically advanced race which
sounds a lot like later contact D
descriptions of another planet
on a more occult note van valkenberg
claimed that the Adept communicated with
him telepathically and could assume the
forms of friends and family alive or
dead
the Adept also had an agenda just like
the future space Brothers he had come to
cure Humanity of its evil ways and Usher
in Universal Brotherhood
van valkenberg was chosen to recruit
others to get the ball rolling
but it wasn't all love peace and
happiness those lights weren't just for
illumination
according to Van valkenberg they could
transform into a death ray capable of
melting mountains and destroying whole
armies
such technology the Adept warned had to
be kept out of the hands of the Unworthy
especially war-like governments agent
bone found Van valkenberg's Story
utterly unbelievable but he was also
intrigued
like many later contactees van
valkenberg seemed unshakable in his
conviction no matter how goofy his story
sounded
bone decided to join the cult in Hope of
finding out what was really going on
he was subjected to a masonic style
initiation and spiritual tests
supposedly demanded by the addict
Boone discovered that the whole business
was somehow mixed up with the esoteric
fringes of Mormonism
among other things the Adept promised to
reveal the location of Mormon prophet
Joseph Smith's missing remains
the story also resonated with
semi-apocryphal Mormon beliefs in God's
many worlds and the Heavenly father's
supposed home on a star or planet named
kolobe
unfortunately bone never solved the
mystery
concerns arose that he'd become too
close to the cult and lost objectivity
in early 1918 another FBI investigator
Robert Whitson took over the case and
prosecuted van valkenberg and his
comrades as suspected spies
when that didn't pan out Whitson had van
valkenberg and his key Lieutenant
declared selectively insane and packed
off to the state Asylum
they didn't stay long
but whether they got up by recanting
their improbable story or just agreeing
to shut up about it is another unknown
what makes the story important I think
is that aside from the differences in
terminology it sounds almost exactly
like something that might have come out
of the mouth of a contactee 40 years
later
it also argues that the experiences of
adamsky Van Tassel and others can't be
wholly dismissed as confabulations based
on science fiction movies and Cold War
paranoia
maybe the spookiest element of the
emerging UFO Mythos with a Sinister Men
In Black or mibs
a very sanitized version of mibs would
later star in a string of popular films
but the real thing got its start with a
strange case of Albert Bender of
Connecticut
Bender made a big splash on the UFO
scene in 1952 when he founded the
international Flying Saucer Bureau a
research group that boasted 1500 members
following year he sensationally
announced that he'd solved the mystery
of the saucers and would soon reveal all
instead the 32 year old UFO researcher
would even more sensationally claim that
his Revelation had been quashed by the
order of a higher source
he shut down his research operation and
stepped away from flying saucers
Bender explained that he'd been
approached by three men in black suits
who told him while he was right about
the nature of UFOs he couldn't say
anything or else
some suspected he conjured up the tail
to extricate himself from the UFO swamp
but there was more to Albert Bender
in addition to UFOs he was fascinated by
you guessed it the occult he kept a room
of creepy pictures and artifacts he
dubbed his chamber of Horrors
the occultist Alan Greenfield says it
included an altar to practice ritual
Magic
Bender's MIB story took off when an
enterprising if somewhat unscrupulous
publisher named gray Barker got a hold
of the story and spun it into a
best-selling book they knew too much
about flying saucers
from that point on Men In Black are
something like them became fixtures of
UFO lore
Georgia damski called them the silencers
to George Williamson they were The
Intruders or negative space
intelligences
the worst of them he claimed came from
the dying worlds
in the Orion star system enlisted after
Earth's natural resources and maybe our
delicious Souls
besides ill-fitting FBI style black
suits mibs commonly exhibited other
characteristics that made them
especially disquieting
they usually strike witnesses as oddly
foreign looking or even not quite human
one sub-variety dubbed cadavers
resembles gaunt reanimated corpses
others seem robotic here again we get a
hint of shape-shifting
in occult lore the black man was a
well-established figure almost always an
avatar of the devil or one of his
demonic lieutenants
circling back to George hunt Williamson
his view the space intelligences took on
more metaphysical and more menacing
elements over time
in 1954 he connected with a Midwestern
saucer group called The Seekers
it was led by a 50-ish woman named
Dorothy Martin with a background in
theosophy and the I am movement she
channeled space beings called the
Guardians
these Guardians warned that natural
catastrophes would obliterate Chicago
and other cities
but her Seekers would be saved by being
taken aboard flying saucers that has a
certain familiar ring to it doesn't it
the date of Doom was December 21st which
came and went without anything
calamitous happening
The Seekers were thrown into utter
confusion
Williamson later reorganized their
remnants into a new mystical order the
Brotherhood of the seven rays
based on additional channeled messages
from ascended masters slash space beings
Williamson eventually LED them off to
the highlands of Peru where he hoped to
make contact with the Masters and the
saucer jockeys who were all part of some
great Cosmic mystery
that didn't happen either
a very curious incident occurred along
the way however
in 1956 two of Williamson's followers
bumped into another American Dr Andrea
puharic in Mexico
accidentally or not
puharic was an army-trained brain
specialist who took a deep interest in
ESP in telepathy
he was probably linked to the CIA but
that's another story
in 1952 there's that year again puharic
conducted channeling experiments using
an Indian psychic known as Dr vinod
v-node made contact with entities who
called themselves the nine and
ultimately claimed to be
extraterrestrials
the nine coughed up cryptic bits of
information including the first half of
a complicated mathematical formula
puharic was astounded to discover that
Williamson had channeled the second half
of the formula
concluded he and Williamson were in
contact with the same thing whatever it
was
to baharaj it confirmed that something
very very weird was going on and one way
or another there probably was
maybe no one better epitomizes the
connection between occultism and UFOs
than a man I've mentioned earlier Alan H
Greenfield an occultist for more than 60
years an expert in gnosticism
neopythagoreanism and ritual Magic
a member of The kabbalistic Alchemist
Church a former member of the Ordo
template orientis and a member of the
society for psychical research
Greenfield's also a veteran member of
the national investigations committee on
aerial phenomenon or nycap
in the early 1990s he wrote a book
titled the secret Cipher of the UFO
knots which leads us back to Aleister
Crowley
the book's basic premise is that UFOs
are manifestations of powerful non-human
entities dubbed UFO knots who can appear
as gods angels Devils or Secret Chiefs
whether these beings are
extraterrestrials or some alternate
Dimension is unclear and really doesn't
matter
the euphonates are here and they always
have been
over the Millennia according to
Greenfield these euphenots maintain
contact with a group of Select humans
who collectively constitute an informal
Illuminati
the illuminated humans communicate with
the euphenots and among themselves
through Alchemy secret societies and
most importantly a cipher
Aleister Crowley The Story Goes received
the cipher in 1904 when the eufo not I
was embedded it in the book of the law
Crowley however didn't recognize it at
the time
the cipher was only fully worked out in
the 1970s and 80s with the aid of
computers
much like the Kabbalah the cipher
assigned numerical values to letters and
the words they formed
grossly oversimplified it means that
different words with the same value have
a cult connection or correspondence
for instance the name of George
adamsky's desert venusian orthon decodes
a 68 which is exactly the same as Jesus
but does that mean orthon is Jesus or
that he's just like Jesus or even
somehow the opposite of Jesus well
that's where interpretation and
intuition come in
but for those who use the secret Cipher
to unlock unseen connections things such
as Origins and logic don't really matter
all that matters is that it works and
many swear it does
the examples of UFOs in the occult I
have offered here are by no means
exhaustive
but hopefully they've been enough to
show that the two are inextricably bound
up with one another and that they always
have been
magic seems to appear in the most
unlikely places
no figure of Russia's revolutionary era
has received more mythologizing than
grigore yaffimovic Rasputin The Mad Monk
Rasputin's enemies saw him as nothing
less than an instrument of evil working
to destroy the tsar and Russia to hear
them tell it they didn't kill a man but
a devil but Rasputin's story is clouded
with lies suspicion jealousy and hearsay
next time we'll examine the influence of
the occult in Revolutionary Russia